[Musique]
encore une nuit de feu et de flammes à
kharkhiv où les frappes se multiplient
ciblant des quartiers résidentiels
la place de la liberté de la deuxième
ville d'importance en ukraine a été
bombardé
les russes viennent nous libérer ironise
c'est ukrainiens ont souvent un cadavre
les corps sont extirpés du bâtiment
administratif cibler des secours
s'organisent tant bien que mal
il ya beaucoup de dégâts de tués de
blessés 10 e bénévole c'était une frappe
aérienne très probablement on ne connaît
pas le nombre des victimes je veux bien
garder l'espoir plongé dans le noir ont
raison du couvre feu inga yat sen co
résidente de karkhiv témoigne d'une
journée en enfer depuis deux jours et
les confiner dans un couloir adossé à un
mur porteur et serrant son chat contre l
île appartement qui brûlent des fenêtres
défoncer les gens blessés qui pleurent
qui écrit par une qui nous ont perdu
leur maison
et les sorties hier pour acheter de la
nourriture
hier je suis sorti au supermarché pour
faire la queue pendant deux heures
sous le bruit des tirs pourtant les gens
restés là il ne partait même pas il
s'appuyer même pas ce que tout le monde
avait besoin de se faire des réserves de
provisions
les sirènes retentissent partout en
ukraine les civils se réfugient dans les
abris la russie multiplie les menaces et
des attaques tout en demandant aux
ukrainiens d'évacuer les villes
plutôt à trièves une tour de télévision
a été ciblé par des tirs de roquettes
tuant des passants face à l'offensive
russe inga se sentait puissante mais
tellement petit devant l'armée qui fonce
sur nous on nous attaque une attaque de
partout et cesser complètement un
impitoyable je suis heureuse de ne pas
faire d'enfant pour ne pas leur faire
supporter cet enfer un enfer dénoncé par
le président céline ski devant le
parlement européen
le bombardement de karkhiv a été
dénoncée comme un crime de guerre par le
président et lenski qui ajoute qu'il
reste ouvert au dialogue avec les russes
à condition qu'il cesse de pilonner les
civils ici s mitraillette radio canada
montréal